sino que además tenemos una primavera
helada el mensaje de la naturaleza algo
quiere decirnos tu leonardo parece es
escéptico no no no a mí la naturaleza me
tiene podrido teoría para ser sincero
batería que indica que el cambio del
recalentamiento al planeta está haciendo
que los flujos marítimos los flujos de
aguas oceánicas se vaya sacando más
lentos de modo que eso bulería una nueva
edad de hielo y esto se sumó reportaje
hecho donde hay áreas sobre todo en
uruguay donde el campo magnético también
se está enloqueciendo está está está es
el lugar más débil y es lugar justamente
que también
protege al planeta de la reactividad de
los rayos solares entonces estamos
cuando caminamos por las montañas y a
veces uno ve los extractos de las
formaciones geológicas
y nos enseñan que hay estratos que
estaban eran horizontales y que de
pronto están así están en posición
vertical una de ellas la ve el piso es
claro cuando uno puede imaginarse el
line la inmensidad y la magnitud de los
cambios geológicos y tectónicos entonces
mientras eso está bien démonos por por
por salvado digamos de alguna forma de
esas tragedias ecológicas si el guión es
nada dentro pero por otro lado acaba de
salir una de una investigación acaba de
publicar un atlas del clima aquí en
canadá se le fue realizado por la
universidad de winnipeg es único en este
en su tipo en el mundo y es un análisis
hecho a base de 12 modelos climáticos
que permite a cualquier ciudadano
canadiense empresas quien quiera entrar
en ese mapa
que con una base de datos increíble y
que permite predecir a día que hacia el
2050 qué temperaturas va a ser en canadá
en 200 cuanto a las 2000 ciudades y
pueblos de todo canadá y es realmente
impresionante por ejemplo dice que en la
ciudad de winnipeg en el 2050 se cree
que va a hacer 40 y 3.8 grados celsius
casi 44 grados como la india más o menos
cuando en un periodo entre el de 1976 y
2005 la temperatura promedio era 34 o
sea de 34 pasamos a 44 es una barbaridad
o también hay una previsión y se pueden
hacer en base a esos datos cualquiera
puede hacer
van a aparecer los resultados por
ejemplo en la ciudad de toronto lo que
decían también es que por ejemplo
si se mantienen si no hay cambios en los
gases de efecto invernadero en el
combate contra los gases de efecto
invernadero en toronto esto no va a
tener un promedio de 53
de aquí al año 2050 superiores a los
treinta y pico de grados cuando en ese
mismo periodo dos mil 976 2005 las
temperaturas fueron solamente 12 días
con temperaturas mayores de treinta y
pico grados entonces es muy serio el
tema y lo interesante de este sitio es
que está
permite pues además da muchísima
información a los canadienses y
cualquiera que entienda inglés y francés
puede entrar al sitio da muchísima
información sobre qué es lo que está
pasando y cómo combatir también ese
problema que la naturaleza nos está
diciendo entonces yo la pregunta que me
hago es si aquí en un país nórdico vamos
a tener temperaturas en ciudades
canadienses no estamos hablando del
lejano norte estamos hablando de acá del
centro y del sur de canadá superiores a
40 grados que es lo que va a hacer en
toda la zona en guadalest
que es lo que va a ser no tengo la menor
idea pero es muy grave entonces lo igual
también había una proyección hace un par
de años salió una proyección con
respecto a
el descongelamiento de los polos como
suben los niveles del agua y que las
costas de montreal no existiría por
ejemplo dentro de 100 150 años si el
proceso sigue a ese ritmo está bien
igual son proyecciones puede pasar lo
contrario o puede pasar efectivamente
eso o peor nadie sabe qué es lo que va a
pasar de aquí adentro 20 años por ahí
encontramos cómo poner
o solo artificial no se existe supongo
que la tecnología debe estar ahí
tratando de encontrar algún tipo de
solución pero pero es dramático y lo más
dramático de todo es que hay líderes de
grandes potencias del mundo que
contaminan
horriblemente este hermoso mundo que
vivimos que dicen que no que no que no
somos nosotros es más salió una
articulación par de días en la prensa
canadiense decía que dos o uno de cada
cinco personas cada uno que cuatro de
cada tres de tres canadienses creen que
tiene cambio climático no está droga del
ser humano no es obra del ser humano y
de las actividades industriales así que
para que vean que el problema es
bastante más serio que solamente
porque en el 2050 son 30 días de más de
50 grados de calor el problema es que si
no la gente no toma conciencia esto no
se resuelve de ninguna manera y si no
quieren creer porque no sé qué es lo que
hay que mostrarles para que crea aquí
está el aire acondicionado y la
calefacción
los escépticos y los escépticos bueno y
acá tenemos entonces con las noticias
las noticias inéditas no sé si tienen
alguna leonardo pero me llamó la
atención hay una una línea aérea europea
no sé si esa eurostar una cosa así
está reclutando gente por tender para lo
que no saben lo que es tiende a tender
es una aplicación de citas se lo pongo
mi perfil
y pongo las cosas que me gustan entonces
me aparecen personas del sexo opuesto
que tengan un perfil que coincida con el
mío yo puedo aceptar o rechazar generar
una cita y salir con alguien
eso es tender bueno este caso pensaba
que era una tableta
entonces y resulta que esta empresa está
basó su publicidad dentro de ti cndr y
está reclutando gente como si fuera
como si fuera una cita
una persona que está dispuesta a hacer
entrar en relaciones de negocios en este
caso pero bueno está euro no me acuerdo
exactamente el nombre de la de la
empresa ya había reclutado gente por
facebook y por twitter creo así que no
me extraña que también le funcione este
nuevo método
no lo que me había llamado la atención
era justamente este tema de la
universidad de winnipeg y este atlas del
clima que me parece algo extraordinario
como fue hecho y que de hecho los
invitamos a nuestros escucha veedores a
que visiten esta de la universidad no
está para además en lo que es
interesante cualquiera puede entrar
entonces voy a buscarlo en dónde está
porque no tenemos ahí el sitio en la
pantalla así que está ahí
está el título es 43 grados en ciudades
canadienses en el 2050 y que es un sitio
que además fue comentado por david
suzuki que es uno de los grandes
ecologistas investigadores canadienses
donde justamente él menciona este atlas
y la utilidad del atlas no es ahí
tenemos en la pantalla gracias a la
magia de leonardo
el tema del que estamos hablando y ahí
en ese lugar pues está el enlace donde
pueden entrar al sitio de la universidad
de winnipeg y si saben inglés y están ya
están pensando hacerlo en otras lenguas
para que todo el mundo tenga acceso muy
bien grupo valencia doble hoy todo
sonreír
es una historia muy cómica porque se
trata de primera
estos son los elementos estamos en
victoria columbia británica técnica que
es la ciudad donde se encuentra el mayor
número de personas adultos mayores
primero y segundo quizá es el lugar más
monárquico de todo que nada no es
contario no es es victoria y en esta en
esta ciudad está un célebre y ximo hotel
el que es un gran hotel el fairmont
empresa es un falta que toda la cadena
enfermos y por todos lados en
norteamérica y en el mundo
es un hotel antiguo que he construido
por villarreal en su momento de apogeo
de la industria ferroviaria inicio tel a
las 5 de la tarde a el día que sea la
hora de la hora del té y es un hueso
inglés súper inglés
carísimo carísimo creo que está una
galletita costaba 80 dólares quizá
exagero pero nada por ahí una taza de té
no se los aconsejamos por una galletita
80 dólares y lo que pasó es que hace 17
años un canadiense de las atlánticas
rento una habitación de hotel hombres
nec board show y este hombre viajó con
una maleta llena de pepperoni picante
entonces tenía tienen una reunión
entonces dejó la maleta pero abierta en
su habitación
y estuvo ausente todo el día y cuando
volvió se encontró con una escena
increíble porque por un pequeño edificio
entre 20 a 40 gaviotas se metieron a su
habitación de holanda está y él decía
que nunca no sabía que las gaviotas
babeaban y cuenta que todo tipo de
líquidos salieron por todas partes por
daños y perjuicios
pero él había invitado una reunión de
negocios con gente en el restorán abajo
entonces subió arriba no tenía cómo
cambiar se abrió una ventana no llamó al
hotel trató de sacar todas las gaviotas
por había algunas reticentes aún aquí si
tiene un zapato y se fue por la ventana
el zapato y la gaviota así que le
faltaba el zapato
entonces al final tuvo que pues
finalmente pedir auxilio y el resultado
concreto es que el hotel le prohibió
volver a poner los pies en el hotel y
fue una condena herramienta que no le
haya cobrado los daños que causó
así que después de 17 años volvió esta
semana el hotel le levantó las sanciones
tenemos que el señor esté vivo todavía y
que vaya en señal de reconocimiento y de
agradecimiento
este este hombre nick versión le envió
como gesto de cortesía al responsable de
hotel y una maleta llena de pepperoni
picantes
desde de gaviota eficaz
[Risas]
la moraleja es que hay que city si
viajas con maletas llenas de pepperoni
picante que la ponga bajo ya axis y
relación con éste pues que había gente
abajo esperando y vieron una una
explosión de plumas zapatos que caían
toallas que caían agarró una gaviota la
envolvía la gaviota en la toalla la tiró
por la ventana cayó la el zapato sobra
gente la gaviota el escándalo de la
realeza en ese momento en el que dice
saludos javier gonzález nungaray dice
saludos también luis balderas the
silence' envió un afectuoso saludo desde
chile interesante el tema de los cambios
relacionados con el cambio climático
estuve en la antártica el mes pasado y
sorprendió me sorprendió ver un musgo
verde en el suelo cosa que años no se
veía en la isla rey jorge en shutter
land del sur y después otro mensaje
javier gonzález nungaray que dice amigos
periodistas de radio cara internacional
en español muchos saludos ahora escuchan
escucha viéndolos tranquilamente desde
casa así que hoy javier no está
trabajando en su taxi le mandamos un
abrazo grande también bien
valderas cuál es el nombre de nuestro
amigo chileno
valderas pero me preguntaba cuál
escuchara lo que estaba leyendo leonardo
el comentario de luis cuando nosotros
estuvimos en una bud lo único que se
veía en el piso de enerjay lo y piedras
eran líquenes es que los líquenes son
los musgos son primos hermanos hay una
similitud entre lejano norte canadiense
entonces la antártida estamos viendo si
emerge de la antártida no se veía el
musgo nunca porque está tan congelado y
tan alto una capa de hielo tan grande
que no sabe y ahora se ve eso es lo que
remarca quiere decir que se ha derretido
bastante esa capa el cielo bueno y
hablando de la antártida me permite a mí
me da pie para lo que me sorprendió como
noticia
inédita que he hecho ahí está la foto
fue que se hizo en un este en una base
en la parte de una base científica
alemana que se llama neumayer 3 y en
esta base hay un invernadero pero que no
es un invernadero como los otros no es
de vidrio este invernadero y en este
invernadero en la base neumayer se hizo
la primera cosecha de verduras
qué que hizo este que sembró este equipo
científico que se encuentra de
científico de alemanes que se encuentra
en ese lugar en la antártida y bueno
cosecharon 3.6 kilos de lechugas 18
pepinos y 70 rábanos esa es la cosecha
afuera está haciendo veinte y tantos
grados bajo cero y lo curioso es que de
este invernadero es que es un
invernadero aeropónico que ellos llaman
no funciona con la luz solar sino con
unos rayos ultravioletas con unas
lámparas de rayos solares más las
crearon a las primero exacto exacto
entonces y la idea de todo esto y de
esta cosecha lo interesante es que ellos
de aquí al
el verano próximo piensan a aumentar esa
producción y este invernadero está
construido como un módulo espacial la
idea es que cuando vayan al espacio
cuando comience a marcarla la conquista
del espacio y que ya sea que vayan para
amarte que es el proyecto más habitable
me imagino que la piel
verduras frescas verduras frescas en el
espacio y yo sigo pensando y muy
interesante son sigo sigo regresando a
nunavut ustedes se acuerdan cuando
estuvimos en una boutique nos
sorprendían tanto los precios de una
naranja
que sigue sorprendiendo porque es
tremendamente elevado a costa a raíz de
que hay que transportar todo pues por
aviones no y justamente en uno de los
viajes que hemos hecho en una bud y ya
se estaba implementando un proyecto de
invernadero para producir sus propias
verduras en una bud justamente con el
objetivo de
los precios es carísimo no sé en qué
habrá estado pero me hace acordar un
poco la solución para eso están tan
rudos no imagino que a esto se puede
agregar el hecho ese descubrimiento ya
que se puede inclusive cultivar asados
en laboratorio
así que es artificial todo son las
fibras que no es carne verdadera lo que
dicen es carne verdadera porque son las
mismas células sólo que es alimentada
por de otra forma houston no no si no ha
probado
hidropónicos a la luna tranquila
hidropónico también algún mensaje llorar
si aquí tenemos otro mensaje de luis en
balde la gente dice en la base china
great world también tiene un invernadero
ese es el objetivo de este invernadero
este producir alrededor de 5
los de frutas y verduras por semana
entonces el proyecto es ambicioso me
pareció interesante de que en un clima
como el de la antártica la antártida de
a veces me confundo no sé si esta
cantidad
en la antártida se pueda se pueda dar
este tipo de agricultura y de proyectos
espaciales pues se cayó su satélite es
un satélite y frustración espacial el
chino ya entró en él
gross o el pacífico de la el problema
era que no se sabía con precisión dónde
iba a caer que eso era lo que preocupaba
a la gente porque esta caída era libre y
no programada a veces las caídas que la
nasa prepara de satélites y todo esto
los programas y hay un hay un momento en
la rotación de la tierra en el que
permite si se hace en ese en tal pero no
frecuencia y va de sergio bitar jr
y se va a caer en un lugar en general en
el océano pacífico pero está como era
caída libre no había ningún control
entonces eso lo que preocupaba un poco
al oriental no pase lo que pasó en la
película un cuento chino que le quedó al
pobre una vaca
pasternak
bueno vamos a entrar de lleno ahora sí
vamos a darle rienda suelta a este
castor cibernético con los mensajes de
nuestros oyentes a ver quién se lanza yo
tengo aquí esma el zamora dice saludos
desde salvatierra guanajuato me he
colocado en agua potable y frutas
tengo un mensaje de robinson mosquera
hace mucho que no nos escribía son de
colombia y dice hola saludos desde
colombia deseó entonces poder ser
reportero de un día para el programa de
canadá en las américas café además dice
espero sus comentarios y saludos deseo
intercambiar cartas en inglés con
personas de todo el mundo
el envió este mensaje por facebook no en
nuestros sitios entonces las personas
están interesadas a lo mejor en
escribirse con robinson mosquera van al
sitio facebook y ahí está su dirección
su no todos y gracias a todos los datos
allí y si robinson quiere podemos
también con su eterna cita y hacer un
reportero donde ya sabe vía skype en
directo sólo que no sé si porque robison
esté en el sur de colombia en una zona
muy medio selva está degradada y no sé
cómo están las conexiones internet es
por allá por ese lugar pero podemos a
consultarles y de ahí pues se
procederemos en consecuencia grupo
completo de mensaje de alguien que no sé
si será realmente
su nombre verdadero porque se llama pone
firma por lo menos como alberto samsung
ok debe ser medio coreano
no debe ser primo de roberto iphone
samsung escribe sobre el tema algo raro
está sucediendo con el campo magnético
de la tierra justamente lo que
hablábamos él dice jesús viene pronto
esa es la única razón de todos estos
cambios busquen la biblia todo esté
escrito en ese libro santo de lo que
está por venir a este planeta bueno es
muy creyente él no hace pues muy bien yo
tengo aquí un comentario dice las
profesiones con salarios más elevados en
canadá están en alberta lismar gonzález
escobar dice buenos días mi nombre es
luis mar soy de mexico radicó en el
estado de nuevo léon municipio de
monterrey tengo pensado viajar a canadá
en aproximadamente 4 años nada más que
estoy buscando que profesiones son las
mejores pagas y con más demanda en
canadá es un placer estar en contacto
con ustedes gracias y excelente día y
animar gonzález escobar le decimos que
bueno justamente en ese artículo puesto
a la venta
detallado y ahí seguramente un vínculo
que va a llevarlo al sitio oficial para
saber cuáles son las profesiones más
pedidas en este momento y yo creo que lo
que quiere saber es cuáles son las mejor
pagadas también existen exigencia de
ello se trata el artículo así que debe
estar sillón ahora acá tengo un
comentario sobre un tema incendio en
cuartel de policía en venezuela había
dejado 78 muertos dice escribe louis luz
y dice no hay que descartar el incendio
provocado por personas ajenas a los
reclusos que buscan crear la imagen de
que a los presos se les trata
injustamente las investigaciones deben
llegar hasta las últimas consecuencias
la derecha no descansa en poner mal al
país buscando la intervención militar
por parte del imperio pero se quedaban
con las ganas y si quieren la
presidencia tendrán que obtenerla con
votos esto escribe louis luz desde
venezuela muy bien roja que es por ahí
algo sí aquí
un mensaje de javier gonzález lugar de
justamente sobre la persecución de
género principal razón de las mujeres
que buscan asilo en canadá quien dice
una felicitación al gobierno de canadá
por darles asilo a todas estas mujeres
que verdaderamente sufren de violencia
doméstica en sus países de origen
aqui en mexico estos casos son muy
frecuentes pero las mujeres que pasan
por esto tienen miedo de hacer una
denuncia formal dice el bueno muy bien
yo tengo aquí dos cortos mensajes de
antiguos oyentes de la onda corta que
son desde hace años uno de ellos es
osman y cabrera herrera de cuba' él dice
saludos al colectivo del castor saludos
desde cuba un fiel oyente cubano de la
antigua radio canadá entonces pues
muchísimas gracias osmany y tenemos
también a nuestro buen amigo hablábamos
de venezuela horita de éste tenemos a
nuestro buen amigo jairo castillo quien
dice cuando quieran estoy disponible
para el castor mensajero saludos a todos
rc y desde el bello estado sucre en
venezuela leonardo gimeno sí tengo aquí
un pequeño saludo de guild en abril que
dice una en la escuela en guanajuato así
que saludos español y si correspondía
este sí porque me imagino que hay a la
orilla del mar en nuevo brunswick que el
mensaje de méxico dice un tema en el que
adquirió muchas que causa mucha reacción
entre nuestra audiencia más crece lópez
obrador en sondeos más con del pánico en
washington una entrevista con john
ackerman carlos rico dice en respuesta
al wifi de montilla no hay punto de
comparación la ciudad de méxico tiene
aproximadamente el 60 por ciento de la
población que tiene venezuela manuel
lópez obrador fue el alcalde de la
ciudad y por donde la veas mejor o es un
buen administrador catalogado como el
segundo mejor alcalde del mundo por la
encuesta de alcaldes del mundo así que
wilfredo responder enfócate en comer
a los más de 30 millones de venezolanos
y no pierdas el tiempo mal informando y
difundiendo temores infundados el pri y
el pan son los que ya pusieron a mexico
como venezuela por eso no los queremos
basta recordar que calderón inició el ex
presidente felipe calderón inició los
gasolinazos y las balaceras de los
narcos por todas las ciudades peña nieto
y med continuaron con los gasolinazos a
partir de ahí los precios de todos los
productos subieron porque todo se
transporta dice carlos rico a sobre la
de la candidato manuel lópez obrador en
las elecciones que se vienen en mexico
muy bien y en ahora tengo un comentario
sobre primicia mundial en canadá se
implanta glándula tiroides en el brazo
escribe georgina villescas y dice hola
me detectaron cáncer en tiroides y me la
quitaron estoy subiendo mucho de peso se
puede trasplantar otra glándula de
tiroides es la pregunta que hay así que
para nosotros es bien difícil contestar
porque pues no estamos muy bien ese
artículo estaba bien explicado nos vamos
si se puede
y entonces porque l a nuestro artículo y
quizás pues se puede encontrar más
información médico en su país donde
pueda tener más detalles
el mensaje después un mensaje más largo
en este caso bendito re se nos dice
abrazos fraternos desde costa rica
cariño especial erótico trabajado un
blog con end y un placer y pura vida has
querido andy bueno y el mensaje que
quería leerles es este de cecilia so en
respuesta a dan a que escribía para el
artículo médico canadiense dice que la
diabetes tipo 2 es curable y dice en
respuesta a dana estoy realmente muy
agradecida de esta información es
sumamente importante que las mujeres de
hoy se preocupen de estos temas al igual
que muchas madres con diabetes yo sufrí
de la angustia de no saber qué hacer
para tratar mi enfermedad
afortunadamente encontré la solución y
comparto con ustedes es un nuevo
producto que sirve para revertir la
diabetes lo puedes encontrar en el
siguiente enlace y mandó un enlace en
este en este mensaje esto me llevó a
entender todo acerca de la enfermedad
desde porque se tiene hasta cómo hacer
para curarse
hoy soy una persona normal y no tengo
que preocuparme más te invito a leer
detenidamente el enlace anterior y
confía en la solución de tu enfermedad
que está más cerca de lo que crees dice
besos y buena suerte
cecilia pero antes de entrar en los
temas que nosotros resaltamos esta
semana es bueno recibimos corriere
recibiendo correo aéreo y evidentemente
desde cuba entonces te quiero acusar la
recepción de estas cartas que nos envían
antiguos oyentes de la onda corta de
radio canadá internacional e incluso
aquí tengo una de maricel guilarte tanta
ou que escribe al club de amigos de
canadá
y ella pues nos escribe desde guantánamo
cuba luis camarillo desde el paso texas
a bueno mira de eeuu todavía con una
carta que nos viene de parte de luis
camarillo
tania espinoza pérez nos escribe desde
holguín cuba
justina maria saldívar sal
ella nos escribe también desde holguín
cuba y danny álvarez peña nos escribe
desde bayamo granma cuba bayamo o
vayamos
así la temperatura sigue como está bueno
vamos a para variar vamos a resaltar
nuestros temas esta semana quien se
quiere lanzar primero yo no tengo
problema es un artículo sobre el mito
que descubrió en realidad no descubre
desarrolla el mit
el mitin digo que él estaba allá era una
herramienta para combatir el acoso en
línea porque eso es un problema es un
problema grave es un problema gravísimo
cuando
pasa a ciertos niveles el acoso y en
este caso
hay un grupo de investigación de la
mighty que está tratando de encontrar
una solución entonces se ha creado un
portal ha creado una herramienta para
que las personas que bajo una
investigación importante descubrieron
que los acosos la gente que es acosada
no tiene confianza en los moderadores de
los correos electrónicos por ejemplo que
es una de las vías del acoso entonces
que se escudan mucho y se hacen se los
sostiene su entorno familiar o de amigos
entonces lo que han creado es una
herramienta donde uno puede crear una
cuenta y contactar a la gente que esté
de acuerdo por supuesto y hacer de
filtro porque dice que digamos está
también basado en la cuestión de
inteligencia artificial pero hay matices
de la lengua que la inteligencia
artificial todavía no comprende entonces
es complicado para cuando cuando hay
cosas que mensajes que tienen algo de
odioso dentro del mensaje pero que la
inteligencia
adriano no lo puede captar entonces pasa
y esto lo que propone es este sitio de
internet esta herramienta para hacer
como un team work con un pequeño equipo
de gente para hacer el soporte técnico
entre comillas de la persona que esté
siendo acosada así que toda la
información en nuestro sitio
en ese punto sea leonora rojo no sé yo
me estoy volviendo cada vez más
desconfiada con todos estos aparatos que
aparecen cada vez uno más con todo los
de facebook estas noticias el cuántos
canadienses salió hace poco 80 80 mil
canadienses también los datos de 80 mil
mejores 380 mil si es algo muy concreto
muy concreto es que cuando yo tengo mi
cuenta y mi compañera entro a mi cuenta
a facebook
yo no estaba en facebook mi cuenta
estaba activa desde brooklyn así que no
tengo la menor idea de cómo era posible
dicho avatar que está ya en brooklyn y
yo bueno eso se puede hacer y eso es
relativamente fácil si uno logra yo
tengo por ejemplo un vpn
virtual private network y yo pongo la
dirección ip de donde yo quiera serlo me
conecto para facebook desde china y
ellos ven que estoy conectados de china
está bien eso es relativamente fácil lo
irónico del tema es que todos nuestros
datos sin facebook y sin twitter todos
nuestros datos están ya spam y cannes no
es facebook el problema es que permitió
la utilización ni siquiera fue facebook
el que lo permitió pero bueno en una
discusión pero el tema es que uno cuando
uno si uno lee las letras chiquitas del
contracto ahí dice que uno está expuesto
y uno pone en foco hay gente que pone de
lo que come voy saliendo voy saliendo
estoy en tal dirección hermosa la
capilla tal en tal dirección llegó a
casa en 40 minutos la primavera
y eso siguiendo lo que dice leonardo
cuántas veces hubo estas advertencias
que yo leí que decía sí
se va de vacaciones no lo ponga en
facebook porque igual mañana me voy de
vacaciones por tres días voy a estar
ausente ya lo saben por ejemplo pues yo
la última vez que me fui de vacaciones
compré los pasajes y la línea aérea
comunicó con google y google lo puso en
mi agenda directamente pues entonces hay
una comunicación ahí que uno está
absolutamente desprovisto de
herramientas para seguir la edad de edad
de piedra lo que pasó lo hicieron hace
cuatro años atrás y está hablando hace
cuatro años atrás que habían puesto un
stand como si fuera una persona que
adivine el futuro en europa y una carpa
y el tipo estaba sentado ahí y le
entraba una persona suele decir bueno
dime tu nombre de metro pedido de mano
de vives y te diré de edad de tu vida y
le decía eso y empezarán tatata hasta
que llegaba a tu cuenta bancaria está
little tal y la presencia realmente
adivino con que que está pasando acá y
bajaban la cortina y del otro había seis
que entraron y sacaron toda la formación
de esa persona o sea la información está
ahí
está en la nube y preocupamos por que se
acordara un personal no sé ustedes se
acuerdan que estaba en un hotel en una
convención una gran reunión y desde su
pieza en el hotel este tipo había
entrado a los datos de las personas que
asistían a esa conferencia y cuando fue
él fue a dar su conferencia sacó los
datos sin mostrar todos los detalles
pero dijo no es fácil y claro para los
conocedores y los hackers y los que
saben de eso como leonardo allá pues es
seguro que es fácil no acceder a esa
información de no hay que tener el
conocimiento y el conocimiento y algunas
herramientas no es tan difícil el paso
en una convención de seguridad
informática en eeuu se hace también 45
años atrás que un hacker lo llamaron
para digamos una presentación una
presentación y la noche anterior se pasó
a hackeando los teléfonos de todos los
invitados y todo los conferencistas y al
día siguiente dijo bueno esta
información es entonces la misma persona
con toda información de todos los seres
sin ningún tipo de problemas dando
detalles y detalles dice a que no voy a
entrar porque esta persona estuvo
visitando tal y tal sitio o sea
evidentemente él era impresionante y
estamos hablando de hace cuatro o cinco
años de ser terrible
bueno sigamos con nuestros temas porque
el tiempo se va como agua entre los
dedos tenemos cinco minutos
leonora bueno yo destaco una entrevista
que hice con el doctor manuel montero
odasso él es profesor de medicina y
medicina geriátrica en la western
university en ontario que hizo una
investigación que permite predecir si
una persona mayor tiene riesgos serios
de caídas de caerse porque bueno no
todos los mayores se caen pero hay unos
que están más predispuestos no y él
decía por ejemplo el efecto en un
reciente estudio de él dice la mejora
cognitiva de las personas mayores puede
resultar en una forma complementaria de
reducir las caídas porque porque el eje
el efecto de los ejercicios
no se ve solo en los músculos sino
también mejora aspectos cognitivos
relacionados con la salud del lóbulo
frontal en el cerebro traduciendo esto
lo que lo que hicieron con esta
investigación es que teniendo todos los
datos se puede predecir con dos años de
anticipación ellos pueden en estado de
una persona si se va a tener caídas o no
en los próximos dentro de dos años que
eso es lo más interesante de esta
investigación entonces como hacen esas
predicciones están xxi que tienen que
hacer después me imagino lo que hay que
hacer exactamente pero en ese sentido
está cerebro y físico javi todas las
ciudades
hablan de edades no en realidad
casi me moleste con el médico porque
hablo de mayores de 65 años porque yo
tengo entendido en algún momento escuché
decir en algún lado no recuerdo
efectivamente donde que las personas que
son de 85 años para arriba
y se quiebra en la cadera y quebrar todo
pero es que no es que se caen y se
quiebran la cadera se caen porque se
quiebra en la cadera o sea en el
envejecimiento normal del cuerpo hay una
debilitación interesante importante de
todo el sistema óseo y una de las partes
más que quedan más debilitadas en la
cadera y por entonces se rompe y luego
es la caída eso es había ahora cómo se
rompe bueno porque el hueso el hueso
está débil y entonces hay un esfuerzo
demás y se rompe y se cae es que se cae
porque se debe a un trastorno en la
velocidad de procesamiento de los
reflejos ustedes deben haber visto por
ejemplo gente mayor yo lo veía en
argentina un señor de 80 años subiéndose
a la escalera al techo y martillando no
coordinan bien éste no pueden hacer
múltiples tareas se concentra en golpear
pero se olvida que está parado en la
escalera y después puede caerse si no
tiene cuidado bueno ninguna entrevista
que hicimos con félix villalobos
es una pasante venezolana que está hacia
una pasantía en el centro el comité por
los derechos humanos en américa latina
ciudad con el hospicio de quebec sin
fronteras y el programa y la ong de
desarrollo y paz ella es periodista ella
pasó por telesur trabaja ahora en el
sistema de radio fe y alegría donde
tiene impuestos de impuestos de decisión
y lo central era saber cuál es el estado
de la de los medios de comunicación en
venezuela y básicamente lo que dicen los
medios en cada vez que hay una dictadura
que estudia que después a una persona
que viene el terreno la pregunta fue en
venezuela hay o no una dictadura la
respuesta de ella es que no hay pero que
hay un sistema autoritario entonces y
que la batalla es básicamente tratar de
encontrar dar voz a todas no solamente
las dos sino a la mayor cantidad de
voces posibles para entender lo que está
pasando en el país y finalmente concluye
indicando que los canadienses están mal
informados sobre la situación venezuela
bueno muy bien en rcn
y punto se pueden escuchar eso muy
rápidamente lo que yo les invito a
escuchar es un reportaje que de cierta
forma da seguimiento a una noticia que
habíamos publicado en nuestra existencia
en internet con respecto a la
desaparición de este niño
ariel jeffrey kwaku que desapareció el
12 de marzo todavía no lo han encontrado
pero esta semana bueno eso el sepa al
parecer todas las pistas llevaban hacia
un parque que queda en el norte de la
ciudad y empezaron a hacer búsquedas en
el parque a pie a caballo desde portones
búsqueda submarina pensaron que se había
caído el río bien esta semana
suspendieron esas búsquedas y
entrevistaron al padre de este niño que
es quad yo frederick kwaku y él decía
que estaba muy contento estaba
satisfecho de que se suspendieran
búsquedas submarinas porque a su juicio
en su hijo no se ahogó y su hijo está
vivo todavía y que alguien lo tiene
secuestrado y el hecho de que se
suspendan las búsquedas de parte de la
policía de montreal en el parque les va
a permitir de concentrarse en la pista
que ellos que la familia favorece que es
la pista del secuestro bien eso en rcn
punto se hace no se acabó el tiempo este
programa los pueden escuchar la versión
audio de este programa las pueden
escuchar en rc y net punto sea el sábado
el domingo y bien esta inversión tendrá
la música agregada que esta semana
estará a cargo de sound méndez quien
ganó recientemente el premio y uno del
público y eso fue todo por ahí no nos
podemos despedir sin decirle adiós a
nuestros amigos
bueno adiós
pareciera de chau adiós